hi Barry
if something happens I need you to hear
this
I iris and West take you to be my
lawfully wedded husband until death do
us part
get ready for the season 3 finale of the
flash tomorrow
[Music]
hey everybody little new flash to get
you ready for tomorrow
I know it's mostly focused on iris West
Candice Patton did the end of that promo
so there's a whole bunch of fun stuff
that we have to talk about but then
there's some really serious Justice
League Zack Snyder news that was
released so I'll explain what's going on
but you've probably been hearing a whole
bunch of stuff just because the news
broke literally in the last couple
minutes is I'm making this video so
let's start with the flash stuff is a
little bit happier even though we're
dealing with the death of iris West and
nobody thinks I feel like nobody at this
point thinks that she is not going to
come back during season 4 it's just a
question of how and I think it all has
to do with the solution to fixing this
avatar problem there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video because what is
savat are but a future version of barry
so if they're able to change the future
or change
savat are himself then they can save
iris because he's the one that's been
messing with time just like Barry's been
messing with it I mean that's the whole
reason he exists because Barry mess with
time so if you're confused yes iris West
is probably the person who died in this
moment that's what they're telling us
and the only way to fix it is to fix
avatar himself so if Sava tarde never
existed then he wouldn't exist to kill
iris West here in poof she come back
into existence but based on the season 4
synopsis that I talked about during my
last video I'll link that at the end of
this they released it it has a whole
bunch of characters that you're
wondering whether or not they die in the
finale so it's like oh my god if they're
coming back then what does this say
about the events of the finale there's
all those pictures that's so savat are
working with Barry so either they have
to team up or saboteur has to change his
plans because right now all he's
thinking about is becoming a god there's
still a couple really big powers that
the flash is not unlocked yet that's the
way I'm going to think about it so Barry
you know could still save the day but
what I'm hoping to see in the finale is
in manifest the new ability especially
something that will help carry into
season for one of the big ones they
haven't dealt with is his ability to
focus speed forward energy for an
immediate takeoff so the flash when he
runs really fast has to get up to speed
like he starts running fast and he runs
a little bit faster he builds speed and
really achieved enough kinetic energy to
either throw lightning or jump really
far or go back in time but he actually
doesn't need to do that eventually in
the comics he learns to harness the
Speed Force so that he sort of charges
himself with energy and can go from a
complete standstill to Lightspeed but
you realized the problem in this is that
one he'd have to focus his energy so
he'd be incredibly vulnerable while he
was doing something like that and if he
were able to run Lightspeed on a dime
whenever he wanted there would almost be
no show there'd be no conflict because
he'd be so much faster than everyone
else so we haven't talked about it too
much but there's the idea of Savitt are
running through pure speed force we saw
that earlier this season they haven't
used it a lot because I guess it's a
really expensive special effect for them
to do but that's what's happening here
he's not running through a normal time
space he's jumping into the Speed Force
with someone then jumping back out
that's why it looks like he's a bolt of
lightning whenever he touches down isn't
it funny that he can't do that anymore
now that he is fully in the real world
he was doing that while he was still
sort of half trapped in the Speed Force
so if their egos away at the end of the
season it'll be really fun to see him
come back just like a bolt of lightning
so what's going to happen is is they'll
probably release some more footage
tomorrow morning so whatever it is I'll
do new video for it
there's also supposed to be a new Game
of Thrones trailer in the next couple
days and there's new Wonder Woman
footage tonight during Supergirl so
depending on how much stuff drops when
it drops I'll do videos for that but the
really big news you've probably been
hearing about Justice League is that
Zack Snyder is taking a leave from the
movie that means he's stepping away from
post-production which is what they're
doing right now before they do reshoots
they finish the film now they're editing
it they're doing special effects all
that big stuff and then they're going to
go do some reshoots and then that'll be
the end of it but the statement that
Warner Brothers and everyone is
reporting is the Zack Snyder is stepping
away to be with his family because way
back in March when they were actually
filming the movie one of his daughters
died he took about two weeks off they
stopped the thumb for two weeks so that
he could deal with the tragedy with his
family but he said he felt like going
back to work would just help him get
through this so come to a couple months
later they're in post-production and he
just realized that it's just too much
like the death of one of your children
is way too much for you to try and work
through so send all your pas
the vibes out to him and his family
he'll still come back for the premiere
of the movie he'll still help them out
when they need big questions but working
on a movie as big as Justice League is
something that demands so much of your
attention that he just can't be with his
family to grieve and help finish the
movie at the same time so what they've
done is that they brought Joss Whedon on
to the movie you remember he's doing the
Batgirl movie they brought him on to
write a bunch of extra scenes for
Justice League earlier this year and now
he's fully taking over the movie he's
going to finish editing he's going to do
the reshoots so most of the movie is
Zack Snyder's vision with the help of
Geoff Johns all the other people that
have more working behind the scenes but
now Joss Whedon is going to be a big
part of that so if you have a situation
like this where someone's dealing with
the family tragedy in the project is
this great Joss Whedon is really the guy
you want to get the guy who did the
Avengers movies the guy who writes the
best dialogue one of the best ensemble
Directors in the business so none of
this is bad news for the movie is just
really bad news for Zack Snyder and his
family so all my thoughts go out to him
this is probably part of the reason why
you heard people talking about major
justice league reshoots is just that
behind the scenes they had to bring in
somebody to help out because Zack Snyder
was having such a big personal tragedy
so the movie is fine nothing's going on
behind the scenes everything else is
going great they've almost found a
director for the flash movie it looks
like it might actually wind up being
Robert Zemeckis now there were a couple
names on the table but they're shooting
the Aquaman movie right now you might
have seen some behind the scenes
pictures so that ECU is doing really
well and I'm seeing Wonder Woman on
Wednesday so my arrow finale video will
be a little bit weird I'll post
something really quick but I'll be
watching the Wonder Woman movie while
the arrow finale is happening so I'll
just remind everybody about the video
scheduled on Wednesday but I'll totally
post a non-spoilery Wonder Woman review
so far everybody that I trust all the
critics whose opinions I really value
they really like the movie so I'm really
optimistic it sounds like it's going to
be a lot of fun so let me know what you
guys think about all this it's a lot of
news to handle the flash there's so much
stuff going on with the finale Savitt
are what's going to happen to Barry
what's going to happen to iris and then
all of this Justice League DC EU news
with Zack Snyder and his family in
what's happening with Joss Whedon behind
the scenes it's all kind of depressing
but there's a lot of good stuff
happening too so focus on the good stuff
send your
positive vibes out there what you wait
for everything to post you can click
here for a new flash and to learn all
about what's up with season 4 they
release the synopsis and you can click
here for new Game of Thrones promo
breakdown thank you so much for watching
let's high-five I'll see you guys
tonight